Hey, I'm Jad Abumrad,
this is a more perfect a mini series a that we're just getting going about some
of the ideas and the cases that flow through the supreme court.
And we're going to start the series off with, uh,
with a story that isn't so much a courtroom drama.
This one is about an issue that I think everybody agrees is about to land at the
Supreme Court. Again, in a big way.
Story comes from reporter Karen Duffin and it begins with a mystery,
right? Uh,
all right, so we're starting with Maya, right? With Maya Maya Fella.
I am the director of the death penalty team at reprieve.
Okay. So Maya PFOA lives in London and um, when she was about 25,
she had graduated from college, she was doing some theater things,
but she was like having this quarter life crisis and didn't know what to do with
her life college, that's Sorta nice central crisis.
And I wrote to a couple of organizations and said, you know, please,
can I be useful to you?
She ended up volunteering at this place called reprieve legal organization that
the death penalty cases, are they like a bunch of lawyers or what do they do?
Yeah, like they do legal work and advocacy.
They've been working on the death penalty for like years at that point to try to
abolish it.
I've used the death penalty and I viewed it at the time as sort of the sharp end
of a series of societal injustices. So anyway,
she's at reprieve. One night,
this was 2010 I was sat in the office and she's sitting there one night and
Clive Stafford Smith who's the president of reprieve or the head of reprieve
calls and says, look, we've got an execution tonight.
There's an execution in Arizona tonight.
Free Landrigan is set to be put to death for killing Chester dryer.
Landrigan was found guilty of strangling and stabbing the man in 1989 so Clive
says there's an execution tonight and we just found out that the lethal
injection drugs that they're going to use, they came from a pharmacy in England,
but we don't know which pharmacy because Arizona refuses to release the name.
Does anyone in the office have some time to volunteer?
Have some time to figure out where those drugs could have come from.
And she raises her hand and she's like, I have 30 minutes, you know, I said,
yeah, sure I've got, you know, I've got half an hour. You know,
I didn't know what I was starting when I started it.
Why they want to find this supplier? Like why does it help them?
Well the drugs that they want to use in Arizona have to be FDA approved.
So if they can find who made these drugs and prove that they are not FDA
approved and they can probably stop the execution,
do they have any reason to think that drugs weren't FDA approved?
It was kind of a hail Mary.
So I started the half hour research task that has taken me now five and a half
years and I was trying to figure out with limited information where sodium
thiopental could have come from in the UK to get to the u s sodium thiopental is
an anesthetic and for a long time it was one of the most common anesthetics used
in surgeries, but it's also one of the drugs used in lethal injection.
I was sort of, I didn't,
I don't think I knew the puppets of all the resets that I was doing,
but I was doing it very quickly because of course they an execution that night
Landrigan is running out of time and options and it was, I was in the UK,
so it was the evening, which is morning Arizona time.
We had just a number of hours.
She's like frantically searching through all these like global medical
regulations and you know,
she can't figure out exactly what the name of the company is because there was
no way to know at that point.
But ultimately she does figure out that there are no UK companies authorized to
ship this drug.
To the u s there was no effectively no FDA approved supplier of the stuff.
So whatever this mystery pharmacy was, it probably wasn't FDA approved.
And I remember, you know, I emailed that over.
I think we either tend to intern affidavit from me or from Clive.
They write up a quick affidavit,
they send it back to the states and the execution that night was stayed like
halted when I went to sleep. It had been stayed and I just thought, okay, great.
You know, we've got a bit of time and the next morning I woke up,
I was couch surfing, I was in someone's hand. I turned on wealth service and a,
they announced
Jeffrey Landrigan was executed at 2126 hours.
Um, yeah,
his final meal was a piece of steak.
His last words were, well,
I'd like to say thank you to my family and boomer sooner.
It turned out while Maya was asleep,
the state appealed all the way to the supreme court.
And late yesterday the justice is by a five to four vote lifted the stay of
execution, allowing land are going to be put to death. Last night they was,
was put in place due to concern over lethal injection drugs.
One of those drugs obtained from Britain was not FDA approved,
but the u s supreme court did rule that there was no reason to believe that the
drug wasn't safe. So jeopardy,
I've had a rude awakening. The literal sense
[inaudible]
yeah, that rude awakening would, uh, Send Maya on a journey around the world.
It would get her called out by the United States Supreme Court and it would
spark a global conversation about the American death penalty and about those
little words, cruel and unusual that are embedded in our eighth amendment.
The honorable, the chief justice,
and the associate justices of the Supreme Court of the United States.
Oh, Yay. Yay.
Watson's having good than before. The honorable,
the Supreme Court of the United States red mine to draw on Aaron Canberra
[inaudible] space in this honorable card.
Oh yeah.
All right. Back to Karen. So we in London with Maya,
who just learned that Jeffrey Landrigan had been executed,
but to understand what she does next,
let me just give you a little bit of context.
[inaudible]
fall of 2010 when Jeffrey Landrigan was executed, the drug that they use,
the lethal drug sodium Theo pentacles, suddenly in really short supply,
there was a nationwide shortage because the only us company that's still made
that drug with having like a manufacturing problems.
So they had stopped manufacturing or producing this drug.
So you actually see these emails between states like, Dude,
do you have any sodium thiopental California got help from right next door.
Arizona agreed to lend California a cup of death and there's actually been some
one great email exchange between like the California Department of Corrections.
They send Arizona this thank you email writing and I quote you guys in Arizona,
our lifesaver. Buy You a beer next time I see you.
You're a lifesaver. Yes. Come on. Yeah.
So when Jeffrey Landrigan is set to be executed,
Arizona is out of that drug and this is how they end up at this mystery drug
company in London.
So after the execution, my is doing all this research,
she said she's calling Pharma companies on through these documents.
And very quickly she learns that the same company that is sending drugs to
Arizona had sent drugs to like lots of different states, wheelchair,
South Carolina, Kentucky, the Fornia and various other places.
They'd actually become one of the primary suppliers of lethal injection drugs to
the United States. Wait, tell me again,
why was it so hard to find out information about this company?
So what happens is that um, anybody involved with an execution,
your name is kept confidential and states have started keeping companies names
confidential to oh I see.
So next she starts calling suppliers and distributors.
Kinda tried to trace like how did this drug get to that company thinking that
maybe that'll lead her to it.
We had figured out it had come originally from,
there was an active ingredients made in Australia.
Some of those was sent over to Germany. The package put into vials,
those were sent over to the UK. There was one company that had,
it has the marketing authorization for the product.
They were sold to another one.
That company changed it and then they were sent to this company in England,
which he still can't figure out the identity of.
But then the real breakthrough came just a couple months after Jeffrey Landrigan
was executed. I think there was lots of material coming out at that time.
I remember California and the ACR,
you've got a batch of documents and in one of these batches of documents,
she finds an invoice and this invoice has a name on it. Yeah, I just,
I just remember getting the court documents and I was,
I was working with this very slow Internet connection.
She was actually in Malawi at the time, just sort of, you know, perfectly,
you know, willing the computer to download the documents so I could start,
you know, looking through them and figuring out this stuff.
And those were the documents that had the name of the middleman.
What was it? Dream Pharma Dream Pharma Dream Pharma Dream Pharma.
Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Yeah. So she's in Malawi,
so she, you know, rings up her colleague and says, can you go,
just look at this place. It's in West [inaudible] London
and it's this um, residential area,
but also like with sort of warehouses kind of class.
You have a couple of petrol stations,
a couple of cafes and then this pharmacy,
except that it doesn't look like a pharmacy because it's got a big sign on the
front that says, uh, l gone driving academy.
You can try and
knock on the door of the gum driving academy.
This is Nina Paris. She's a freelance producer in London.
It doesn't look too good as is. There's a
tiny little storefront by the,
can't see any evidence of driving. And if you walk in,
hello,
you walk in and in the front it's just this reception area, but in the back,
hi, I'm, I'm looking for dream farmer.
Is that you? Hi, I'm recording.
Well, there's a guy sitting at a desk. His name is many Alavi.
He's in his fifties, gray feathered hair, kind of like square glasses.
Looks a little bit like William hurt. He is dream Pharma. In other words,
the company that is helping prop up the death penalty system in America.
It's a one man operation operating out of the back of a driving school.
One Guy, one guy. And I thought,
well this can't be true,
but they're interested in speaking to you, um,
about the injections for that you supplied to the states from the get go?
I had no comments and I still have no comments. So,
um, what was it like when the brief, uh, came to find you?
Ask them yourself, what was it like for you? Ask them for yourself.
Okay.
Are you still supplying the states with no
rights? Did you, were you aware of that? It wasn't illegal at that point, right?
So then it became legal? Correct.
Would you mind me asking how you came to get involved in that in the first
place? How they came to find you or you to find them? They found me.
They found you. Wow. Were you surprised when they got in contact with you?
I don't know,
but I guess it unraveled somewhat to
no further comments. Okay. Well, thank you very much for
doing that.
And thank you for bringing me to acting cause I very much enjoyed walking around
that in the meeting. People around here. Okay. Yeah. So at what do you,
what do you sell now? [inaudible] your case.
I'm just quite interested, isn't it? As a citizen of London,
you're 11 you're not in the business. That's irrelevant to you. Okay.
Okay. Well thank you very much for your [inaudible]. Sure.
And what was your name again? Please will know my name if not, find out. Okay.
Thank you very much. Well they year. Bye Bye.
Do you think actually do driving lessons?
You don't do driving lessons?
It's Maya and reprieve. Found that guy,
meti Alabi in his pharmaceutical broom closet of death.
The next step was pretty simple.
They went to the UK government and they told them because in the UK it's illegal
to be part of capital punishment in any way.
We have a law that prohibits exports of product
for the facilitation of capital punishment or torture.
It's called the torture regulation, anti torture regulation.
With this text you need in the world.
The EU is profoundly committed to the fight against torture on the death
penalty. And when they realize
that the sole purpose of the export of this drug was for executions,
they put an export control in place and just like that,
the supply of this drug is turned off. So the states are just out of luck. Well,
I mean,
60% of Americans support the death penalty so that they're not going to give
this up without a fight. And so
over the next few years you have like this arms race,
Missouri says we're going to find the drug in Germany.
So Maya goes to Germany and then she hears that a company called Hospira is
about to make the drug in
eight to eight. And so I spent a bit of time there.
The Italian government really didn't want drugs made in the seat of the pope to
be, um, dues for execution. The Hospira aspects person said,
we cannot take the risk. That's,
we will be held liable by the Italian authorities if the product is diverted for
use in capital punishment. Yeah.
And then Denmark, bunch of states, Florida, Ohio,
Alabama, 11 other states,
they all decide they're going to get their drug from this company called Linde
back. Maya calls them up and I remember my first call with that. She was like,
um, did you know that your drugs being used in executions? And they were like,
what?
It certainly came as a huge surprise for us. This is Andrew Schroll,
he's vice president for communications at booned bag.
We have been a in the Pharma Industry for a little more than a hundred years and
we are here to save people's life.
This was a complete opposite of the intention of this product.
And Maya says that she heard the same thing all over the world.
Even when states like Nebraska and South Dakota go to India to get their drug.
And it's interesting in India because India has capital punishment.
So this isn't an objection to capital punishment.
This is from every company I've spoken to in India. They say, but why?
Why would they use medicines? Like if you're going to kill someone,
just kill them.
Why are you using something that saves lives to do it?
And actually there's a really interesting story about why we do it that way.
Oh, Yay. [inaudible]
that's coming up on more perfect.
He's from Washington, from snap, snap, Dakota live walks,
Nashville Wyman theater flooding March 16th and I'm bringing the best Doritos in
the world. Fry laughs a more amazing night out. And yes,
she's coming. The funniest woman in the world. Jen Kober.
I do my hung in the lady forest, Jen Cobra rocks a brand new story.
GIG tickets. It snap judgment that org.
I've never gotten applause for it before. If you guys could call my mom,
that'd be awesome. She's still pissed.
I am Jen. I boom Rod, this is more perfect.
A mini series about some of the ideas in cases that are flowing through the
supreme court. Back to our story from reporter Karen Duffin.
So we left off with Maya in India and they're wondering why do you guys use
drugs to kill people? Why? Why would they use medicines?
So what is the answer to that question? Why do we, well,
the answer to that goes back to this guy named bill Wiseman.
It's a terrible thing to have. One,
it's reputation and B, B, based on, on, uh,
coming up with a new way to kill people,
Bill Weisman was a rising star back then. He loved politics.
Wiseman died in a plane crash in 2007 and this is him in an interview with a
reporter named Scott Thompson on t v in Tulsa back in 2005.
So what is, what's Bill's story? So he grew up, um, his dad's a minister,
his GRANDPA's a minister and he's like, I don't want the family business.
And he wanders for years. He, he by his account,
wanders through like two and a half literature degrees. He becomes a poet,
he drinks a lot of corn liquor and you know,
he finally ends up in construction where he starts working with politicians and
he's like, oh, this is my calling. I want to be a politician.
So he gets elected to the Hook Oklahoma state legislature in 1974 and he's
opposed to the death penalty. And Luckily for him, this had just happened.
The Supreme Court declared the death penalty unconstitutional today and spared
the lives of 600 men in death row cells across the country.
In 1972 the supreme court actually abolished the death penalty because they said
it was being applied unfairly or haphazardly in a way that could only be called
freakish. So Bill Wiseman is in the Oklahoma legislature and he's like, great,
this is not a problem I'll ever have to worry about.
The problem is the public is furious about this decision.
Okay.
Support goes from 50 to 63% in just two years.
Death penalty should be reinstituted. Yes, I think so. Absolutely.
I very much in favor of Holly in favor of it and we get some law and order enter
this country. There's people writing furious. I bet.
I don't think you should have taken it away in the first place.
And almost immediately, 35 states rewrite their death penalty laws,
essentially saying like, no, no, no, no, no, no. We can do this. Right.
And in 1976 the supreme court says, all right,
if you can administer the death penalty fairly and humanely,
you can have it back.
So 1972 the death penalty is abolished in 1976 it's reinstated.
Bill Wiseman gets elected smack DAB in the middle of this. So you know,
in 1976 suddenly there's a bill in the Oklahoma state legislature about whether
to reinstate the death penalty and bill has to vote on that.
I know the capital punishment, it just, it doesn't work.
Doesn't make sense. I couldn't see any way to justify it.
I also knew that if I'd voted against it from my district,
I would run a high chance of getting whooped
because 80% of his constituents were in favor of the death penalty.
After all that wandering, he finally found this job that he loved. I was just
best time and I didn't want to get whooped. So I was in a real dilemma.
What'd you do? The wrong thing.
He voted to reinstate the death penalty for whatever reasons of ego or vanity or
need or the motivation to get reelected to whatever the reasons.
I knowingly made a decision when I knew it was wrong.
And that's, that's tough.
Nope.
So he's in the legislature and he's feeling like he just sold his soul and as
they're debating various amendments to this law,
someone brings up something sort of vaguely about a more humane way to execute
people. And he's like that. Yes. That, and he becomes obsessed with this idea.
Oh, it's like a way to assuage his guilt. Yeah.
So he rings up some anesthesiologists and doctors and says,
I want to find a better way to do this. And they say,
we can't help you because the, you know, hippocratic oath do no harm.
Death is a little bit of harms.
So he goes to the state medical examiner at guy named Jay Chapman and Jay just
sort of like,
freestyles is one line that that bill literally just sits with a yellow legal
pad and, right. Yeah.
It's word for word. It said a, uh, um,
an intravenous saline drip should be established to a,
into which would be introduced a, uh,
ultra short acting barbiturate in combination with a chemical paralytic.
The idea is that these three drugs would allow them to execute people but,
but painlessly and right there in that office with just like this yellow legal
pad, they invent lethal injection in America.
[inaudible]
it would be hard to overstate just how important this moment in this office is
because you know,
the supreme court had just given the country back the death penalty on the
grounds and the ideal that we could, we could do this right.
And what bill has just handed America is,
is that a way to have the death penalty but, but have it be humane,
the ideal penalty. Yeah.
So Oklahoma adopts it and then the very next day Texas does and then dozens of
states. And since that moment,
88% of all executions have been done by lethal injection.
I don't hear the word lethal injection or execution or anything else without
feeling a tug cause it, it's tied to me. I'm in, I'll always be tied to it,
which he lives to regret.
He thinks that he actually extended the life of the death penalty and he
actually eventually quits his job,
becomes a pastor and becomes a very strong anti death penalty advocate.
How does the man who came up with the recipe for lethal injection or does he do
on Judgment Day and the same thing everyone else does?
Throw ourselves on the mercy of God.
Say that we have done wrong and we're sorry.
And the thing that I find really interesting is that if you look at the modern
lethal injection cocktail, it's three drugs, the firstrex buster,
nice the ties you,
the second drug paralyzes you and the third drug is the asset that stops the
heart and kills you in this drug cocktail.
You kind of see everything that we want and need from the death penalty,
just kind of all mixed together. The third drug,
the drug that stops your heart, that's kind of our sense of justice.
The first drug, the anesthetic,
that's kind of our sense of humanity or kindness. That second drug,
the one that paralyzes their muscles. The second drug is purely cosmetic.
It serves no medical purpose.
The reason it was put into the lethal injection cocktail in the first place was
so that if the first drug doesn't work effectively,
the second drug will mask any signs of visible suffering and it would be
extremely significant because the potassium cried.
This potent acid that people have described as being like fire going through
your veins and being burnt alive from the inside. She says,
just imagine that that's happening to you,
but something goes wrong with the anesthetic and you become conscious.
You have this burning acid going through your body and you are paralyzed.
All your voluntary muscles are paralyzed. So you can't say, I'm awake.
I can feel everything. This is agony.
She says that it's that second drug that is both the thing that could make the
execution most torturous. And the thing that meant that we,
the witnesses, the viewers,
the public wouldn't know that it was torture because we weren't supposed to know
that. So does she
end up going after that second drug, the paralytic? No, actually she,
she goes after the first drug, the anesthetic and it's total coincidence.
This is just the one that had manufacturing problems that started the arms race,
but it turns out that this drug, sodium thiopental,
the anesthetic is the one that's the most constitutionally important drug
because in 2008 when the supreme court ruled on lethal injection,
they said parties agree that successful delivery of the first drug is necessary
to prevent the prisoner from experiencing severe pain.
So there's no anesthetic, there's pain which would be too severe.
And then B, therefore what an eighth amendment violation.
Coral unusual punishment. Exactly. So that drug, the anesthetic is the key drug.
But over the past five and a half years as Maya has like whack of mold her way
across these different companies,
she's just made it harder and harder to get there.
Now 20 plus companies who have,
they've said we disapprove of the misuse of medicines and executions and we're
going to take steps to prevent it and that has stayed scrambling.
The drug use did a 32 death penalty date or now running out.
They have run out of drugs. And as a result,
what you've seen is that things have gotten very DIY,
are changing and trying new procedures never used before in the history of
execution. Prison officials are in a difficult position,
even have the DA start rating prisons complicating the drug during the import
process because they're essentially using illegal drugs at this point.
And so reporters are just starting to pay more attention.
And in the middle of all that, he began kicking his feet,
lifting his head and his chest off the gurney grimacing.
You also get scenes like this clinching a season and a couple of moments,
he actually mumbled,
he would open his mouth and you'd see his chest move and it would go all the way
down to his stomach. So it was a clear gas. Yeah. April 29th,
2014 in Oklahoma, a man named Clayton Lockett was being executed for murder,
rape, and kidnapping block. It's execution used in new drug combination,
whose source is unknown. He was sedated and declared the unconscious,
but he started thrashing, clenching his teeth and started losing the arm.
It took him 43 minutes today, grisly, horrific spectacle,
and this kept happening after an hour and 57 minutes.
The state pronounced him dead. You had situations like this in Arizona, Ohio.
This drug formula is unconstitutional because people started filing a bunch of
lawsuits and one of these eventually got to the Supreme Court case,
1479 55 blossom and interestingly when it got to the Supreme Court.
Yup. I mean let's be honest about what's going on here. Things got very tense.
This is Justice Alito is saying essentially, come on guys,
this isn't actually a problem. You made it a problem.
Executions could be carried out painlessly. There are many jurisdictions,
there are jurisdictions in this country,
their jurisdictions abroad that allow assisted suicide.
Now the have gone through two
different drugs and those drugs have been rendered unavailable by the
abolitionist movement and this is justice Scalia or putting pressure on the
companies that manufacture them so that the states cannot obtain those two other
drugs and now you want to come before the court and say, well,
this third drug is not 100% sure.
The reason it isn't 100% sure is because the abolitionists have rendered it
impossible to get the hundred percent short.
Is it appropriate for the judiciary to countenance what amounts to a guerrilla
war against the death penalty? What do you think he means by that
guerrilla war efforts? Thank you. Yes. Trying to say there are ways to to,
if you want to make the death penalty illegal, you have ways to do it.
You can call your legislator, you can pressure them, they can pass a law,
but you're trying to like hide in the trees and like pulled drugs off and make
them so scarce that you're forcing a legal problem that doesn't exist without.
You should not have bearing on whether it is concierge answer to the question.
You've been interrupted several times. The justices called you guys out,
kind of. You know, it's, look, you know,
there's a lot of narrative around this being guerrilla activism,
but this has nothing to do with me or anyone else.
It's that the companies don't want their medicines used in executions.
The manufacturers, the distributors, the pharmacist, the anesthesiologists, the,
you know, European governments or whoever else. It might be the Indian industry.
None of them asked to be part of Ohio's capital punishment machine.
But isn't there an argument to be made here?
I mean I get what she's saying that like all these different people in different
countries have been like unknowingly drafted onto Ohio's execution team,
which doesn't seem fair,
but isn't there an argument to be made that like even so the effect is that she
has taken a death penalty that is kind of humane maybe and made it more cruel.
I mean, cause that's kind of the accusation, right?
Yeah. It's, it's, I'm going to say two things. One of them is a throwaway.
Um, she didn't cause it. She's,
the states are chasing the companies and she's chasing the states. Right?
So like you can't say that she caused it, but what you, more importantly,
what you also can't say is that it is actually more cruel because there's no
evidence that there's been an increase in botched executions.
What I think is happening is just that we're paying more attention to lethal
injection. Right. We're just looking at it more.
Oh,
you mean like it's botched executions have been happening forever and we're just
now noticing them.
Yeah. Nonetheless,
people do accuse her of making this more cruel and not just because of the
drugs, because states in their sort of desperation to still be able to do this,
are looking for other ways to do it.
And some of those ways might seem like we're going backwards.
The lady that was, uh, spearheaded the, getting rid of the injections,
all she did is basically forced people to be shot.
This is Paul State Representative House, District 13, Utah.
He says one day he was sitting in his office that was actually listening to the
local NPR station and federal judge in Oklahoma is,
and they were talking about European pharmaceutical companies used to provide
this controversial drug, but now refuse to sell it to American prisons. Ah,
the European drug companies no longer selling the drug cocktail.
And so I called our department of corrections and says, Hey,
do we have access to the drug? And they said, no, we don't. Uh, you know,
we have a set amount and then we're out. He says, he hung up the phone,
did a little bit thinking, a little bit of research,
kind of deep into the history and, and eventually he came to the conclusion,
well, let's revert back to the firing squad.
[inaudible]
do you mean like firing squad John Wayne firing squad?
Like line up against the wall?
No, it's like they have a chair and they bring the person into the room and they
strap them to the chair. They put a hood over their head.
Physician will locate the heart and they'll pin a target where the heart is.
And then there's five men with rifles and one of them has a blank.
But none of them know which one it is. And then on the, when the orders given,
they all shoot the individual in the heart.
Law Makers in Utah have voted to bring back executions by firing squad if lethal
injections are not readily available. All races,
he was just trying to solve a problem.
But I was completely taken off guard by the media frenzy that cruel holdover
from the state's wild west days that happened to create relic of old West
justice, real n. It's international condemnation by the unitize.
A document now is an embarrassment of barbaric.
We shouldn't be shooting our people. This is ridiculous.
This is not the time of Moses.
Why is it that the, that do you think the firing squad itself,
it created this response?
Well, it, it's brutal. You know, it's, it's certainly not the easy,
give them a couple of injections and they quietly go down. You know,
this is calling it for what it is. In fact, Paul would argue,
if you want to look at at something that's more humane, he definitely,
the firing squad of what a
caught my attention was that it was so sudden, so quick. Ah, boom, boom.
Just like that.
These are reporters talking about witnessing at firing squad execution in Utah.
It was over pretty quickly.
It was cleaner than I expected and it was fast.
With the firing squad, you know, you're, you're dead within seconds of the,
of pulling the trigger five bullets directly to the heart. It's over.
There's not the paralytic that hides it. It's done.
But, but he moved, he moved a little bit. And
to some degree that bothers me.
Yeah.
That seemed to carry on the last a 60 to 120 seconds.
Okay.
So this is how you tie, has chosen to solve the whack-a-mole problem. Yeah.
And the firing squad has already been upheld by the Supreme Court.
We have approved electrocution. We have death
by firing squad cats, Justice Scalia. In 2008,
the Supreme Court actually approved the firing squad in 1879.
No local jurisdiction the first time.
And the people who are part of the firing squad are actually volunteers.
Do you have a lack of volunteers or an abundance of volunteers
in abundance? I know the last death penalty, they had hundreds of,
nobody's forced to do it. As you know, there, there are people that are willing,
they kind of see as their civic duty, uh, you know, to help carry these out.
And while I was down there, I actually asked Paul,
I really want to talk to a volunteer member of the firing squad.
If you'd put me in touch with somebody who's actually been involved with the
firing squad when we're done, let's call my office. I'll call somebody. Okay,
uh, I'm gonna wait til this thing. Passionate about go.
That's an air 16 pillar four split bombing. Right. All right. I like it.
The founder of freedom, but this is Kenny. We agreed not to use his last name.
And Ken's Dad ran the firing squad for a couple of decades.
So as you see, there's two cottonwood trees over here.
Those old cottonwood trees they'd set up and that's where they would drill the
firing squad at. These men were selected because for one,
there are absolute marksman too. They just hadn't moral clarity,
just they, many of them did not want to be on there,
but once they were called, they felt obligated to see it through.
Ken told me that on execution days, his dad and the other shooters,
they would sit down together at the kitchen table
and you know, it's just like a little family family breakfast and his mom,
she'd make coffee and she would do scones or biscuits and gravy and she wanted
those men to know that it wasn't easy and that she appreciated him.
I know there was a lot of prayer full times around the house when those men are
over getting ready. I know that, uh, I,
it's pretty solemn moment. I,
I the prayer is it for the person being executed, the victim with the prayer?
I think you have to pray for strength to follow through on what you have to do.
I think that, you know,
you might need a little guidance and you might need a little understanding and
something bigger than us out there and
[inaudible]
I think that if we're going to have the death penalty,
people just have to understand that there's some savagery involved in it. And,
and uh, it's unfortunate that it is,
but if we have it to do, let's, let's do it. But let's do it humanely.
[inaudible].
One of the things that I found kind of striking is that Maya FOA is against the
death penalty and you have the folks in Utah that are for it,
but everyone seems to agree that
we shouldn't fool ourselves. I favor the death penalty.
But one thing I've never favored in some common ground between me and the
abolitionists is that lethal injection is a terrible method of execution.
That's Robert Blecker at a New York law school professor sounding a little bit
like Maya, but he says he objects to lethal injection not because of
cool, not because it might cause pain,
but because it certainly causes confusion.
I attended an execution in Florida of Benny Demps,
and I also was with my father in law when he was in a hospice dying from an
incurable and very painful cancer.
And the death scene in both situations was bizarrely similar.
In both cases, the the,
the person dying was lying on a Gurney with an ivy coming out of his arm,
wrapped in white sheets,
medical technicians at his side surrounded by loved ones.
And it struck me as bizarre that we are killing those whom we love in a fashion
that so nearly resembles how we are killing those we rightfully detest.
There should be no resemblance. This isn't medicine, this is punishment. So the,
the firing squad is honest and it acknowledges itself for what it is.
I have one objection to the traditional firing squad that Utah uses.
He says he doesn't like the fact that one person gets a blank and that nobody
knows who that person is. That to me is
symptomatic of our failure.
Once again to take responsibility for what we do. Nobody should have a blank.
And if we cannot face what we're doing and acknowledge it,
then we shouldn't do it.
[inaudible]
and we may be coming to a moment where we are about to do that,
to look at this and acknowledge it because in 2014 in a case that was really
just about lethal injection, justice briar said, look like,
let's stop just talking about the details,
like questions about which medicine that we use.
The time has come for the court to again consider a more basic question.
Uh, whether the death penalty itself is constitutional.
In other words,
what he's saying is it's time to talk about not just like the mechanics of what
we're doing,
um,
but whether we should even do it at all.
[inaudible]
reporter Karen Duffin
[inaudible].
Now, when Briars said that in 2014, he was into the scent,
lost the case,
but a lot of people saw that statement as this invitation like Briar saying to
the lawyers of America send us cases. And in fact,
some of those cases have just started to arrive two days ago.
A case made it in front of the court or almost made it
the last supreme court on Tuesday,
refused to hear an appeal asserting that the death penalty violates the u s
constitution's ban on cruel and unusual punishment to have the eight justices
liberal Steven Briar and Ruth Ginsburg said
they would have accepted the case. Clearly more cases are on the way.
Here's something else that happened while we were reporting this story.
This one from about two weeks ago, no pharmaceutical giant.
Pfizer has announced that it will no longer allow its drugs to be used in lethal
injections.
That closes off the last remaining open market source of drugs use and
executions.
This basically can't quite see spells the end of lethal injection in the United
States, but it's close because now any states that want to keep doing it,
they essentially have to go underground to get those drugs
[inaudible]
more perfect. It's our first radio lab spinoff sideband,
whatever you want to call it. A, it's produced by me. Chad.
I'm rod with Susie Lichtenberg,
Kelsey paget and Tobin low utopian.
Do you want to do the rest of sharp with a Soren Wheeler, Ellie Ms Sal,
David Herman, Alex Overington, Karen Defin, Sean Ramas from Catherine Wells,
Barry Finkle, Andy Mills and Daniel [inaudible]. Special thanks to Ben Cohen,
Mono Lynch, Austin Cert, Chris Zimmerman,
Julie toll and the death penalty information center.
Supreme Court audio is from OEA,
a free law project in collaboration with illegal information institute at
Cornell.
More perfect is funded in part by the William and Flora Hewlett Foundation.
The Charles Evans Hughes Memorial Foundation and the Joyce Foundation
coming up next week on more perfect,
the most important Supreme Court case in the 20th century,
and you've probably never heard
December. Why didn't have their do stray Charles? Stop your banker at out
case was so dramatic, so traumatic.
There was an instance in which my brother found my father going upstairs to get
a shotgun that it actually ended up breaking two justices.
That is next week. Subscribe wherever you get your podcasts. I'm jad boom. Ron,
thanks for listening more. Perfect.